[Music]
welcome welcome welcome
the Tuesday episode of the h3 podcast
this is the experience that you need you
may hear other people talking about
current events giving their opinions on
things but let me tell you there is no
other place on the internet with the
cutting edge informed opinions correct
opinions like here on the h3 podcast
Tuesday's edition so welcome one and all
to the current events experience oh
that's the wrong one there you go
today's episode is sponsored by better
help and just to remind you guys you all
better hurry on down to Teddy fresh
because we're having a crazy sale we
have completely lost our minds end of
season sale fusing 50% off long sleeves
hoodies jackets trinkets beanies hats
y'all better head on down to tell you
fresh cops lush collections / sales Wow
some of these are even sold out so there
is serious urgency here this is serious
let's just get right into it we have the
best opinions here at the HD podcast
you're gonna find out just what I'm
talking about
actually for the rest of the month we
have gas booked and booked booked so the
idea was that we're gonna deliver to you
guys a Tuesday episode with current
events cutting-edge well-thought-out
well informed opinions that are correct
every time they're expressed and if you
disagree it may be time to switch the
channel because these are correct
opinions good for the day let's start
from the top baby you know I was told I
was joking with ela yeah just a week ago
I said you know what is a funny joke
maybe to tweet ela with back to school a
kevlar backpack I was like hey get 50%
off your kevlar backpacks back to school
sale and it looks like tasteless don't
tweet it yeah I thought it's probably
too far I was like okay maybe you're
right maybe I'm just twisted sick
individual
guess what we saw where what what what
new station was the song here let me pop
this up Fox News Fox Business one of
those fox business are we separating
those others different singing yeah
that's pretty much the same thing well
anyway on fox news this is there's so
many layers of greatness to this this is
the goof of the day by the way if you
guys if we need to regiment it out there
you go so they're selling bulletproof
vests
a bulletproof backpack while playing
bulletproof the song sponsored by
Chrysler I was just gonna make a little
joke here they're selling it on the new
sponsor by Chrysler you know it's like
damn it's like Chrysler like the car
company yeah this all sponsored by car
Chrysler school shooting sponsored by
Chrysler yeah high-end bulletproof
backpacks and clothing revenge oh boy
just shoot her point-blank that'll
that'll that'll teach the kids how to
make sure their backpacks works and
remember kids if you want to insure that
your backpack is indeed bulletproof
bring a gun to school and shoot your
friend point-blank it is anticipated to
reach more than 5 billion oh they're
really projecting a lot by 2025 you
cannot project out what seven years in
seven years I'm projected to be the
President and see if that happens
so I thought this was just a goof I
thought this was a total blast so next
time you guys go to the Chrysler
dealership remember think school
shootings sing of a Mack Mack pickup it
with your new Chrysler get a Kevlar
backpack how much is that gonna do and
that's just like well
imagine there's like an active-shooter
you like call your backpack around run
trying to like dodge the bullet and [ __ ]
brought to you by Chrysler so whose
tasteless now Gila
do you think about my ideas now don't do
it kind of a forward thinker aren't I
see I did it as a joke but these guys
are serious as a I want to say school
she traditional saying is as serious as
a heart attack and I want to revise it
do as serious as a school shooting for
as much extra tastelessness as possible
now illa you've heard the saying they're
taking our jobs robots are taking our
jobs I've expressed concern on this very
podcast that automation are taking our
jobs now this video is going to haunt
you it is going to really concern you
and hopefully everyone watching at home
this is not to be taken lightly okay
what we have here is a golfing robot if
they can golf better than us then we are
really [ __ ] look at this golfer
yesterday they robot boom taking a swipe
at this one really you know it's true
you know it's real look at these guys
jumping and cheering for their for the
heralding the end and ten years was not
gonna be golfers anymore so gonna be a
bunch of robots on the field hitting
balls my would go
robots are killing it no football
basketball just me robots that is
actually pretty cool though you won't
see that again yeah yeah really cool
down Robin
kind of looks like the guy that would
play that's insane shot robot dudes
his name is Eldrick hole-in-one so value
your jobs they're coming for him
all of them posts Malone our dear friend
I don't know if you guys followed this
has just happened this morning well last
night he won song of the year yeah VMAs
very proud of him congratulations yeah
he won it for rock star and just I just
I want to congratulate him I want to say
I love him he's a sweet dear great guy
he deserves it and it's insane to see
what he's accomplished since we met him
I mean even just this year we probably
met him like two years ago now but like
this year alone since his new album came
out it's crazy
mm-hmm damn and it's easy to forget was
he's 23 years old okay that should make
everybody at home depressed that
depresses the hell out of me
when I was 23 years old mmm I was
probably playing World of Warcraft and
it's in a disgusting dormitory room with
like leftover burritos I mean I was
going nowhere fast
pretty incredible yeah what a 23 year
old can accomplish so love and pride for
him let's watch his acceptance speech
here you go
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
popular choice on this Punk hold up we
go everybody give it up for 21
give it up the post well
I just want it you know you go to bed
and you dream about maybe winning and
then whenever you get up here you don't
remember what the hell to say because
you wrote it all but you know thank you
so much my solo yeah he's not that tall
he's a tall guy he's not that tall why
are y'all making him I'll act like he's
five - for Christ's sake I mean the guy
it's his big moment why are you making
them hunched over like that that's a
good point you look damn the song thank
you everybody for listening it's fine I
would never you know expect to do this
ever so this is sick and thank you so
much he seems Oh 21 they closed the mic
on us
Thank You Tazawa lower than rank more
can we lower the mic they felt like a
button er like can we lower the mic on
savage by the way I have we were at his
birthday party and I was like man I want
to get him a sick birthday gift cuz he's
like such a good friend he bought you a
really beautiful gift on your birthday
mm-hmm he got ela like this Limited
Edition supreme Fender Strat guitar
there's only like 30 of them in the
world yeah I don't I don't have anything
that is so valuable
other than that I didn't know what to do
I don't know it's a new want to take it
on the wall but he just shows up he
shows up like a couple hours after he
shows up some dude shows up with a
guitar yeah and it was like this
incredible Fender Strat supreme
limited-edition and I was like oh wow
really cool guitar I didn't even
understand that he was giving it to you
I thought the guy just delivered it to
pulse and then he left I was like oh we
forgot his guitar hmm and he was like
it's for me
no I didn't get that but anyway I was
like damn how the [ __ ] do we top that so
well you can't so right you I can't
really but I was like how I gotta get
him a really nice gift so I got I went
down he's a
fanatic we've been to this gun store
together and I got him this cool little
snipey what you just linked me dad what
I think is the guitar that you're
talking about no let's show it we got
pictures on deck
yeah is this one did we are so
interactive we are so this is such an
experience that we can just talk about
something and show it to you at the same
time cutting-edge technology yeah this
is such an experience if only I could do
it with him pretty incredible stuff here
folks
party pretty incredible stuff here folks
okay I I'm still I don't know how do you
display it do you do you frame it cuz it
also comes in a nice box keep it in the
box
get out of the box you take it out of
the box I think you you mean there's
mounts for guitars I think I'm just like
a wall piece I don't think you I think
you just hang it mm-hmm but anyway I'm a
co-owner whose birthday ELA was gone so
I was kinda on my own by the way taking
care of myself which is hard enough as
it is and so I go to this gun shop I'm
like what can I do what can I get
post so he had ordered this this really
cool Glock from them and I was like I
want to get him something dope so I got
him just a little snipey cool asked
leiserson IP that you put on top of the
Glock right not the official name are
you just calling it an IP it's called a
snipe II know it's a it's a scope it's a
sick-ass scope by the way because you
only see it if you look through this
night be whole so if you got someone
locked on they don't see the laser right
here like in the movies only you see it
this might be dead right and I got him
like a thousand rounds I thought I was
feeling pretty good I had like two ammo
boxes a snipey a bunch of rounds and I
was like you know what's the thoughtful
gifts personal it's pretty weird to shop
in to a party where I know it was a big
party and I felt a little bit strange
filling up with ammo at that gun store I
was like are you sure this is okay it's
funny I actually went in there to buy
ammo weapon I was like I'm gonna buy him
a gun they're like - you can't like what
are you [ __ ] stupid you can't buy him
a gun and bring it to a party
how's like oh I guess that does make
sense I guess that's probably a good
thing I guess that's like the one thing
you can't do in America I was like
that's probably yeah that's probably a
good thing
it's funny on one hand I'm like here on
the show being like gun control yeah I'm
like can I buy a weapon and then on the
same day give it to somebody else
they're like no dude okay I guess that
makes sense anyway I bought him a bunch
of ammo a thousand rounds of sniper I
probably spent like $1,500 pretty good
for us yeah I was like damn I hooked him
I'm to do it up and then I calmed and I
was like hey man check out what I got
you and he was very gracious isn't about
post at all this is more a rant against
21 Savage because I had beef with that
guy he doesn't know it so I mean pulse
was very gracious very sweet as you know
he's a perfect angel probably the
closest thing to perfect human being and
then savage shows up and he gives him I
[ __ ] you not like five minutes later
$100,000 watch yeah and I'm like okay
mr. [ __ ] hip-hop you got to know my
broke ass up you know what kind of watch
was it you remember I don't know it but
it was like on the news and now it on
Twitter news where's my snipey in there
and now I see Austin walking around with
his sick ass hundred thousand dollar
watch I don't see him walking around
with this snipey look it's not about how
much the gift cost it's about the the
gesture in this case it was most
definitely about well he loved the watch
it was a great watch it was a great gift
I just honestly wish maybe you could
have waited and giving it to him before
the party you know like maybe a
different time Savage I mean it's kind
of rude to me personally and I do take
it as a kind of a problem
so if you see Savage let him know that
we do have beef don't let everyone know
about anyway congratulations to post
Malone and then
morning that happened last night and
this morning I see my brother-in-law
who's like somehow like we got to hire
my brother to do research this guy is
like in tune with the world yeah he
sends me a TMZ article it's like post
Malone's
airplane is stuck in the air the wheels
blew out when they take off by the way
what how the wheels should blow up when
you're taking off how's that a thing so
he's circling around doing an about to
do emergency landing there in the air
doing circles trying to burn up fuel to
reduce the weight so they can you know
land more safely and so anyway he landed
he is safe we're all very happy about
that we were watching live here in the
office he made this tweet I landed guys
thank you for your prayers cannot
believe how many people wish death on me
[ __ ] you but not today I can't believe
that when I read that I was like whoa I
didn't see anything I mean I wasn't
looking well yeah I wasn't leaving but
people are so insane be like imagine
he's on the airplane like super scared
and he's reading [ __ ] like I hope he
crashes and dies I'm like whoa y'all
[ __ ] me Jesus no I mean I would never
say that to anyone but if you said that
to him you need Jesus can you diagnose
that ELA why are people saying that to
him do they need Jesus or what are they
missing just knew their life okay yeah
so anyway love congratulations
appreciation to post Malone safe and
he's alive and he's looking good he's
got all this suits lately yeah I know
it's crazy
you look thin in that VMA video - yeah
it's a lot of weight I think he's losing
weight he's slamming he's jamming he's a
rock star love is us
now moving on to something more
interesting than that somebody emailed
over the past couple of days an email
that kind of stood out to me and shocked
me he said to me hey I've been listening
a lot to your conversation about wiping
and anal you know cleanliness and
hygiene
mmm-hmm and he says you know what I do
is I near my [ __ ]
I was like whoa there is a topical cream
that you apply to the hair and then you
and then basically it burns it off and
you just wipe it clean so this guy was
like I use sensitive Nair on my [ __ ]
ring and I wiped the Hara I was like
whoa
that is so insane and hilarious I think
I have to try it and I think you
shouldn't because this stuff is like you
could burn your skin I actually I didn't
know what it was I went on Amazon just
to check the reviews and like most of
the reviews our pictures of people who
got burned see any [ __ ] no [ __ ]
more resilient or less resilient right
no really cuz it touches [ __ ] I think
they know well I think that's part of
the charm is that to them first of all
this is very I mean in the pursuit of
knowledge this is like forbidden fruit
forbidden knowledge mm-hmm biblical and
the biblical or an omission it's more
important it's not just a mission this
is God's work you read the messenger if
you read the Bible the story of Adam and
Eve the Apple is the forbidden knowledge
people don't always talk about how they
wipe their ass and clean their ass and
these are important things that we need
to collectively share our knowledge so I
think of myself as kind of a trailblazer
of a kind of a Magellan mmm-hmm Columbus
I don't know I think he was someone who
explored okay I'm an explorer
I'm kind of a darling if you will I'm a
great thinker
they said Isaac Newton he Isaac Newton
said of himself I'm not a giant I just
stand on the shoulders of those before
me
mmm that's what I'm how is that related
because I'm not
swiping giant I I stand on the shoulders
of the wealth of knowledge of those who
have come before me nobody has dared in
the history of mankind as far as I can
tell to collect this knowledge and to
share it with the world this is
important stuff Fela mm-hmm so I think
the pursuit of the forbidden fruit and
the biblical tale of Adam and Eve
there is much the same and so I will
near my [ __ ] in Hebrew and there is
like something you put inside your ass
really when you do that on what is it
and let's say you need to take a pill
but through your ass like medicine
how'd you call a suppository yeah so
that's what that's called in there oh
that's so the first time you said it to
me I was like what do you mean mm-hmm
you good that's almost a sign from God I
mean Hebrew is God's language right so
NER in a way it was almost a Destiny the
destiny all use of NER was yeah so you
kind of supporting my my no no well I
think before not as we come in there my
[ __ ] for better or worse if it burns
if it cures I I mean I have never had a
wipe in recent memory that wasn't Harry
and I think that this could be a gun has
the Metamucil been helping you love it
mm-hmm it's not a cure-all like a lot of
people asking for updates on the meta
music's fiber supplement I've been
taking it to cuz it's so so just fiber
we should be good but like when I didn't
notice any difference in my really yeah
see the first time I took I swear to god
it was like Teflon : I just slid right
out yeah
but for me it's not the end-all
situation like Chris had mm-hmm III have
a hybrid situation I I'm using less baby
wipes but I'm still ending what suppose
well he takes more because there's these
huge pills and they say you have to take
lucky them and thinking whoa yeah
well I'm curious what are you guys you
know I I want not just the the great
thinkers who join us here today I'm
looking for the great thinkers out there
the great minds out there that have
interesting wiping techniques there's a
lecture
dark web yeah exactly so guys give us a
ring today eight oh eight hot meme and
we're looking for great great thinkers
okay so give us a call at eight oh eight
hot meme and share your techniques I'm
very curious to hear what you're doing
okay with that being said we've got so
many great videos come up we're gonna
take a quick break but coming up next do
drinks his own calm in a video that's
fully monetized the channel name is gay
God beautiful and he is living up to
that name he drinks his own come maybe I
don't know if I give you a reason to
close it but it's very funny very I
don't think you wanna miss this with
that being said my dudes Les Cayes could
do a break we'll be right back
thank you to better help for sponsoring
this episode they shoot podcasts I need
some better help I am anxious right now
God seriously but but this is one of
these genius services it's online
counseling mmm they've got fully
licensed counselors ready to consult
with at anytime you get access to
licensed trained fully accredited
counselors and therapists lgbtq+
friendly basically whoever you are what
religion you are couples anything boom
they've got you covered with fully
trained therapists to talk to you all
you have to do is go to better help calm
slash h3 fill out a brief questionnaire
about what's going on with you and they
match you up with a counselor who is a
perfect match for you and you can start
counseling pretty much right away after
they hook you up with a counselor it's
affordable therapy is expensive which is
kind of such BS because everybody needs
help
yeah in fact you might even say poor
people are the ones that have more [ __ ]
to deal with because everybody needs
money but guess what it's way cheaper
than in-person counseling there's a
therapist cost like $300 an hour okay
I'll sure I'll spend half my paycheck to
talk to you but here's the thing
pricing is between 35 to 65 dollars a
week for unlimited counseling meaning
you are connected with a counselor the
entire time via your phone or a computer
you can schedule video phone or text
sessions when necessary usually once per
week they also have financial aid
available that you can apply for if you
need help you can't afford it great
wonderful beautiful what a great service
with better help you're not wasting time
traveling going to and fro a lot of
people have trouble face-to-face with
people it's embarrassing it's tough it's
hard but this is a beautiful thing about
this the service you're online you can
have a video you can have a chat
whatever you're comfortable whatever
level with they're there to help
you out a lot of people are not
comfortable talking to therapist so that
best way to do it to get in the door is
with better help when I was at my worst
with anxiety it was so it was impossible
for me to go into an office and get the
the help that I needed
that's the beautiful thing about better
help so guys if you want me to talk to
somebody for any reason at all this is
the way to try it out go to better help
calm slash h3 give it a shot
you deserve it help yourself out with
better help thank you for sponsoring us
welcome back to the basically if you're
looking for opinions look no further
there's not a rotten guess and this is
the h3 opinion podcast experience
whatever that means
I honestly I'm a little flustered
because I just not used to just three
minute breaks just bring back from the
bathroom literally Yan was like hurry up
they like jumped into the seat at
literally four seconds got my paper
towel we got in here okay
so as promised guys we've got a thrill
ride here lined up this video shocked me
okay it's got been educated that's good
it wasn't before this video shocked me
frankly like no video I've seen in a
long time and the story the scoop
originally was that um it was fully
monetized for a long time which I get I
guess you can only blame you two so much
it's called do vegans actually taste
better so it's like how does YouTube
know that a dude is guzzling his own
jizz on camera the part that really gets
me about this video you were hit by the
way gay god I mean yeah damn
imagine me called like Jew God is
nothing I kind of like that time did you
god so the thing that really pitting
like gets me is that he's kisses in like
a little kind of medicine cup and then
he tastes it and then he's like he loves
it but then he drinks it three more
times and he finishes the cup and I'm
actually getting nauseous as I said
that too for you definitely if you're
gonna drink your hunches on camera like
that you're definitely the gay God not
many people can step to you on that
actually tastes better and I have
actually been vegan for 12 years like
over 12 years so theory than me right I
haven't really tasted myself in quite a
while well what the [ __ ] is wrong is
this nothing weird myself like it like
you're supposed to know what he's
talking about
he's just drank his own jizz nobody
didn't say that yet it's just saying I
haven't tasted myself in a while like
you're supposed to know what that make
people watching readily gay God know
what that means
huh I'm subscribed to gay God challenge
I not a serious on his channel but like
how frequently are you drinking your own
con yeah huh
but how is this not like a weird fetish
like drinking your calm in front of
people publicly it's kind of probably is
yeah and I kind of wanna be open and
honest with you guys and tell you
actually taste like suggested my first
time experiencing ten inches that's what
it says in the top right this is
certainly the gay God might do but like
what I just don't understand like you're
you can be gay like obviously no one
cares that you're gay in this day and
age but like when your whole identity
everything you do and talk about and
every is like about like that you're gay
it's like there's got to be more to you
than that everything's about like I
drank my own chiz I took a ten-inch
cough it's like there's got to be more
to you than that YouTube game that
everyone's trying to play now and like
everything's got to be so crazy like we
used to or we did this video of tasting
different sodas you know in weird
flavors I forgot to tell you that one
now this is
this is no it's like gun this far
so did tasting grow sodas is not enough
anymore know what he should have done it
feel like this is a black guys Cheers
a white guys is a vegans cheers now well
I'm not done you know I watched it all
no we do videos in five times because
face right now all right well anyway
whoa I'll have to bookmark her than my
first time I took ten inches for related
to another day he's not just kidding
though he drinks at all like throughout
the video when I saw that I was like oh
thank god it's not as actually just
clickbait but I promise he drinks at all
and I don't know if I even need to
necessarily yeah I'll know I'll keep
watching and I'll know when I've had
enough you tell me when you're done
watching this okay cuz I don't you know
I'll shut the gate up with a whole bunch
of different guys not a whole bottom
small with making myself sound a little
[ __ ] but I know you're holding a cup
of your own cheese and you're about to
drink it you don't need help sounding
[ __ ] meat-eaters they're so salty
which is weird because I I eat a lot of
salt but all my exes are like yeah
you're really sweet tasty and I'm like
how things are like I eat like ten times
as much salt as you but I guess it has
to do with like a red meat consumption
and all that stuff so they are Oh
wouldn't go had enough you've had enough
you want to see him drink or should we
not really oh yes did it you did it here
yeah let's say Jim let's hit a drink
here
potent smelling like it kind of
oh he drank them already it looks like
less and William oh there you go so
basically I like taking the wipe sniff
of his own kids okay I'm getting nothing
we see enough yeah give us hitting the
button on this you don't want to see him
hit it you don't want to see him throw
it back you don't see a bit you know
what see him throw it back yeah like
like warm sunny d like warm sunny day
all right I'm gonna bounce out of this
yeah you guys want to continue this SOG
on your own head on over to gay God he's
the god of the gays gage okay god I want
to be jugaad jugaad the great thinker of
the dark web what was that group of
people you're saying yella yeah
intellectual dark web yes I'm the guy
I'm the Jew god of the intellectual dark
web what is this intellectual dark web
it's like a collection of the movies
Jordan Pederson and finally and others
in others so am I gonna be inducted in
that for my research into wiping and
we'll see more results you bring back
when your research mm-hmm how would do
we have any interesting calls yet Ian
he's in the middle of screening right
now Dan I don't think I'm logged into
the call oh my
I'll tell you right now yeah he's still
looking for one okay next up break
invasion is back he's dodging I'm alive
I'm trying to get a hold of him and he's
been dodging me a little bit that's okay
once I tell him I'm did you god he'll
have to uh a little bit more
[Music]
how all the audio is like so that's his
style his style it's like torn and
destroyed audio as much as possible
let's take a decision
I'm telling you watch this past 20 vids
they're all like peaked out of this
planet why is there a group of what's
going on behind you crazies are trying
to look like here what is this oh so
there's this rapper 6:9 don't look like
y'all shut you a 6 9 this guy you've
seen him he's like a meme busy tube
guaranteed to come on yeah let's do it
all right so here's the game guys I have
gotten the word that if you can somehow
smash a hundred thousand likes on this
video if we can get a hundred thousand
live viewers right now prank invasion
will come on the show as a guest and
kiss me what if I kissed Chris would
that be shocking will that be good TV
yeah if we do a quick game for a quick
and if he comes in here we kind of do
need to play a quick game for a quick
kiss huh
me and him yeah no not me not you know I
went through I wouldn't volunteer you
for that but would you you're kind of
damaged fine honestly once you kiss
Chris I wonder if we could also get a
girl in here like actor no no okay
I'll do it I'll [ __ ] do it I swear to
god I'll do it I'll do a quick game for
a quick kiss I swear to God and noises
I'll do it dude you think I'm not I'll
do it with this fully neared [ __ ] too
and he would grab your ass full in aired
[Laughter]
dexia turn see how he pulls this girl in
6-9 style hey can sound like 6-9 you
gotta give me a really really quick kiss
you down okay here I go
she's like yep nailed it irresistible
man you know where it goes from here I
gotta say I love Chris it's getting to
the point where it's just so good it's
making parodies of himself at this point
ya know it's turn it's really turning
into something special
we've got current events we've got
everything to talk about everything
going on in the world I'm gonna tell you
guys about it now enter the current
events experience mm-hmm drug overdoses
up 10% in the US what is going on well
it's mostly from prescription drugs
actually shouldn't really surprise
anyone but I have been following this
story I mean here you can see by year a
chart basically since 2016 and and to
this date it's shot up these are all
synthetic opioids basically paint
prescribe first yeah prescription
painkillers way worse than herring yeah
like almost double the debt and if you
go it's interesting if you go back to
like 2012 2013 it was the least deadly
mm-hmm although what kinda going on in
the US if you go back to 1999 people
weren't really dying from drugs but
somehow unliked
and it turned the end of this century
everybody's what's going on people are
profiting from it and heroin cocaine but
it's like all going up is this a
cultural issue or is this well you could
you could say that the whole graph going
up maybe is a cultural issue but
yeah that one spike on the synthetic
opioids right it's not I am I am very
curious about the cultural issue of why
in the past twenty fifty fifteen to
twenty years or is everybody dying from
like what the father I wonder if there's
some explanation or visit just life has
become so unbearable you know it's like
yeah I don't know let's take away health
care let's put everyone in debt and
let's just give them some opiates to
[ __ ] kill themselves on it's become a
lot harder if you go back to nineteen
ninety nine people could buy houses
didn't go to for Brent and over these
past two decades it's gotten a lot
harder to live a lot more expensive a
little harder to get medical treatment I
don't know if that's a relation by
that's pretty sad there's a bigger
conversation here besides the fact
everyone's dying on opioids but that is
the distort here now I've been watching
I just find it so ironic like let me
open this again that there's this war on
drugs like marijuana first of all I'm
not a marijuana user and I think that
it's benefits and it's greatly
exaggerated I don't think marijuana is
an innocent truck but I do find it
absolutely the greatest probably the
single greatest problem with our society
is the fact that 1 percent of Americans
are in prison most of them for harmless
drug offense so it's like we're locking
up marijuana users and meanwhile doctors
and pharmaceutical companies are openly
poisoning people yeah and I mean we're
talking about thirty thousand deaths
that's a small subset of people who are
addicted who's the lives are being
ruined because they're taking so many of
these opiates and doctors are just
giving them out like [ __ ] candy
because they're getting kickbacks
there's like three big companies who
distribute all this and they know
exactly what they're doing
and oh yeah that's just what it is
we saw the 60 minutes report about this
yeah how it was like little pain clinics
opening up probably seen them I've seen
them all over the place I'm like what is
that pain clinic and all family you can
just walk in and a doctor will prescribe
you a painkiller and it's like it's all
super addictive don't give you anything
they'll give you oxy cotton dope yeah
any Opia any crazy [ __ ] you want just
like hey my hey doc my back hurts and
these crooked ass doctors are just
writing prescriptions all day long
my dad he um he had like some arthritic
pain in his wrist and this doctor gave
him like an unlimited supply of like
really intense painkillers yeah and I
was like whoa look if you're actually
two kids so eat and I mean this is an
ongoing issue it's not like it's not
like doesn't debilitate his life right
yeah he doesn't there's nothing in my
opinion that a little Tylenol or
ibuprofen couldn't resolve but like
that's insane
it's so crazy what's going on there and
anyway in the 60 minutes report that I
highly recommend they were showing how
these huge pharmaceutical companies are
basically always lobbying Congress to
not enforce or regulate or control at
all this this growing issue they showed
like for example like there was a
one-town like this is really ravaging
like poor white communities it seems
like in like rural America like Arkansas
and Alabama and Mississippi there was
like a small town in Mississippi or
somewhere that had imported so many and
sold so many painkillers that it was
something like 50 pills for every
resident of the city which means that
they were probably just selling it to
drug dealers but like there's glaring
problems here of everyone drop it like
this this is this is so sick and and the
government's not doing anything about it
because there's so much lobbying money
and meanwhile we're locking up marijuana
users yeah so that's pretty nuts um that
really grinds my gears you know I just
hate this whole like moral there's
always this moral argument from like
army I mean Jeff Sessions the attorneys
general thinks that marijuana should be
like a federal crime
like he's staunchly against legalizing
marijuana it's like okay dude what are
you doing about this [ __ ] yeah like glad
that you've got your moral imperative
about marijuana and and relatively
harmless drugs what are you doing about
this [ __ ] so twisted man [ __ ] can't
believe that it's like Tijuana up there
I've driven past these places when I'm
driving around town you see like pain
clinic I was like what does that mean a
pain clinic what are you what do you do
there I never imagined that it was
actually just people giving prescription
drugs out like nothing I had no idea so
I'm just writing away you were talking
about and yeah like all of a sudden
there is a small town and the pharmacy
will be buying 50 times the amount right
that a normal pharmacy right is buying
yeah and it's like they're just turning
a blind eye or just letting it happen
because the pharmaceutical drug
companies are lobbying the [ __ ] out of
them yeah and blocking it it's like God
Congress is so twisted these guys are so
[ __ ] corrupt it's like scary not to
mention that the water is turning frogs
gay that's a whole other issue
see do you want to talk about this
airplane story yeah or what do we find
it - a little too sad you already
brought it up
yeah what come on is this the video you
put together where's the one you put
together down the the edit it's it's
shared with you share with me we're here
I'll drop it in inner chat right now
this story is a weird and wild one man
and it's kind of sad it's very sad um
this guy I'm not sure how he even got in
the car works an airplane well like how
is it so easy to John there's no key
you think he masterminded this it's not
easy
this guy works at an airplane in Seattle
and he just stole the airplane and went
for a joyride but his intention was was
to commit suicide and what's so
intriguing about it is basically this
conversation was recorded between him
and air control of air control being
like hey man you know bring it bring it
down and he's just he's just so casual
about it he seems like he's having a
good time Dan I don't see it
just drop the Lincoln disk or it didn't
work I clicked it I think I need it but
here I've got it in your you know so
here almost pop this up 21 year old
right for departure just hold hold on
with me for a second yeah so so I'm
fisting about this today just flying the
plane around you seem comfortable with
that I like hitting around yeah what's
so crazy is this what you guys are
seeing is all footage people shot from
the ground mm-hmm cuz this guy was like
I'm gonna try doing barrel rolls and all
this tricks because his intention was to
die so he's almost just like but he was
he was performing some pretty amazing
sleeping like I don't want to hurt
people on the street so he was also
careful of that yeah really interesting
no he definitely wasn't going to hurt
yeah anyone okay and and you can see all
the terrain around you you've got no
issue with visibility or anything I
think I got some guests to go check out
the Olympics and yeah okay and rich you
know able to tell what altitude you're
at you just know I'm not taking it any
jets I'm actually keeping you away from
aircraft that are trying to land at
sea-tac you know screwing up everyone
else's day like a charter plane it's
going down quick this is probably like
jail time for life huh
I would hope it is for a guy like me
I'll return that we're not gonna worry
to think about that but could you start
a left-hander 718 I believe so to go
working on an issue
I don't really know II really need to do
that fixture Irish Sean don't say stuff
like that
George I don't want her do it
I just want you to whisper sweet
nothings in my ear be better than that
trying to land it by the way the
plaintiff and he's all on that plant for
the record you know I think they would
give you a job of doing any second you
think it pull this off right if you want
it to land it just sounds like just bad
your left yeah McChord Field
there's none right here if you wanted to
try that might be the best way to set up
and see if he can land there dang cuz I
don't think I'd be happy with you
telling me I could land like that cuz I
could put some stuff up to here that I
did this
[Applause]
since to you that I did this I would
like to apologize to each and every one
of them screws loose
I guess never really knew it till now
hey by the guy can this make you a thing
like damn I know what's going on dude
it's crazy thing yeah it's amazing it's
sad it's a hell of a way to go but guys
it's seriously [ __ ] get out if you're
[ __ ] feeling bad man
definitely don't steal a plane but a
little follow-up to that somewhat
depressing story this is a charming
charming stuff here I'm just like these
two guys are proposing at the same exact
time it is
come on you gotta love that they both
they double for bugs come on give me a
[ __ ] break would you would you please
give me a [ __ ] break we got a double
proposal here at Disneyland for Thursday
all right
people are luck they're crying they're
freaking out that's at the Magic Castle
come on give me a [ __ ] break here we
got a double proposal am i right this
warped my heart I'm about to wipe I said
you know what
he pulled a ring out ring she was very
cute about it - she was like I don't
know what to do with this
you know both of them were very much
like hmm love it so there you go guys we
get it balance we bring balance here on
the HD peaks and valleys this I told you
this is the premiere experience on the
Internet today
maximum highs maximum lows better help
this one okay we went from sadness to
joy and now to rage like this next story
is really has really made me rageful
we're covering the whole spectrum of
emotions here we have some college
before we take this damn we let's get
some serious yeah
we got a few you want me to put one
through yeah yeah what's their name
all right let's see actually how do I do
it cuz I mean I want to make sure that I
can I can shoot you the link if you want
to right now yes any on discord if you
would please
okay I do you want more story while you
got that set up in the background that
sounds good hey why don't you uh
once you set me up all right and 87
year-old woman gets tased while cutting
flowers mm-hmm
damn all right thank you that's what we
got coming this [ __ ] doesn't work you
know what listen oh yeah and I just has
logged out this is a
mess I mean how long is it gonna take
you what do we got it we got two seconds
here on the clock guys I hope you're all
doing good and having a great time here
at the h3 podcast experience we're
logging into our call studio so we can
get the feedback of the geniuses frankly
that listen to the show and click the
right minds the great minds out there
that listen to this show dan how do you
wipe since we've got you here i I do it
the opposite of you actually then norm
what what I would say is traditional
yeah you're you're a righty I'm a lefty
let's be frank it's not that now do you
go dry or wet I guess I go try I mean I
I feel kind of ashamed and and we've
kind of shame that we shamed normal-dry
now Dan do you ever feel that you just
can't clean it oh yeah and do you give
up or do you wipe to the point where
it's like because usually with dry
wiping you're at it you come to a
crossroad where you're like I give up
too early or do I injure my anus so
where do you where do you fall in that
crossroad yeah no I've been there and it
definitely it's a risky road I mean I
can I'm like you I mean I'm I've got
hair so you know it gets rough it gets
real rough sometimes you take you take
the under wiping or the over harming I I
gotta say I probably do the over harming
because that I mean the other way it's
not okay that's not tolerable so it's
not really an option not for me either
no have you bled from wiping and maybe
maybe I probably don't check enough I'm
a little like I don't I don't turn
around and check out my business after
I'm not ashamed to admit that I've bled
from wiping I have to I have to think
what's going on here
we've dis we've corrected in you've bled
from wiping I have en have you bled from
wiping he said he said yes now Dan you
say madam probably did yeah I think
everyone maybe is an insufficient answer
and I don't I don't turn around and
check do you not look every time you
wipe
ah do you look humble at what point do
you look you don't look you don't look
at the last wipe how do you know you
clean oh I see what you're saying well
yeah I guess I guess in that sense I do
look yes but I'm not like taking thank
you to glance thank you
I fully take it out I inspected
thoroughly they frankly I even look I I
generally even look at the first way
right yeah thank you
now Dan would you say that we all got
our fresh uniform dan has your finger
ever slipped through the toilet paper
because the wet during the dry what
happened to me I don't know Dan yeah and
then and it's if so it's followed by
like 30 minutes of scrubbing my hands
afterwards all right we're in thank you
thank you for the anecdotes they can fix
my computer
thank you specifically to charms for the
flushable wipes oh I gotta hear this um
Kyle I don't know if you're on the air
tell me about tell me about your life or
not I don't want to know everything Kyle
but specifically about the Lyme disease
oh man you open right from the chaser
yeah so I'm a geocache sure you don't
know what geocaching is a little like
GPS based treasure hunt scavenger hunt
type game and a lot of geocaching takes
place out in the woods you know I own
trails and whatnot so before I started
doing this I was never never a hiker
never spent much time outdoors so I
quickly learned that you know down the
trail for a while
sometime nature calls and let me
literally and you know if you're like a
couple miles from your car or something
a couple miles from a restroom you just
got to find a
take care of business so so yeah the
first time this happened I'm a I'm a
hairy guy much like you
so you know it's not it's not it's never
good never comes out clean so the first
time that's happened I you know you
always hear this and I I always thought
it's kind of like a joke but I don't
always hear this but yet I use the lease
to kind of clean up the business back
there and is not preferable so I quickly
learned because I mean as far as my
normal wiping routine goes I'm a dry wet
guy so I'll go my first first one would
be toilet paper and then I got the baby
words right by the toilet that second
and then I just kind of go back and
forth you kind of it's a good way to
kind of feel out the situation without
okay I thing to inspect it after every
what you know and so let's go so yeah
let's go to the the pivotal moment of
the story yeah so this wasn't so on
another occasion because I start
attacking toilet paper in my like hiking
backpack
but on this one particular occasion I I
had run out where I forgot it so I do
not have it with me right so you know I
live up in Rhode Island we take takes
are very prevalent thing up here and
Wendy's as well so so I've never had an
issue with ticks in my life but on this
particular occasion when I popped the
squat did my business didn't have the
toilet paper so I just did the leaf
technique to do you know I'll kind of
take their things a little bit Kyle did
you get a tick on your penis
not on my anus but like two days later I
I felt something uh I think actually I
felt something odd in my groin area say
that I don't want to talk about what I
was doing what were you doing by hand in
the groin you you noticed the tick when
you were jerking off you said that
were you able to finish did you finish
jerking off when you when you found the
tech error or did you decide to go in
there at the time or later
oh no I mean that that ruined the moment
yeah so I had I couldn't see what's
going on I was in bed by now well we're
on your groin was the tick located it
was like right in there like I'm a big
dude so you know like I got some I got
six I'd sure I got the like you
so it wasn't that's why I probably
missed it cuz I always do like a check
it was like like between us I was deep
it was like it was it it was in there
any but like when you say deeper was it
was it under the balls was it between
the balls in the thigh was it next to
the pitchers right it was like yep in
the ball between the ball thigh area I
felt I thought you might agree in an
area you might have been cupping your
balls or something when you were jerking
off right to feel that now you gotta
treat yourself yeah definitely most
definitely good question oh yeah so I
mean you know it's someone you know you
spend time clanking and whatnot
especially around here you know you
always hear about it so I mean I was
freaking out first of all because I
never had a tick bite before so I
already knew the when you want to get
rid of when you want it when yes when
you take it out you don't want to like
break the tick's body or leave it he
bred in like underneath it's like it's
burrowed in the skin like some of it
so did you the technique yeah I use like
tweezers to roll it out that's like and
it you spin it right you grab it and
then you rotate it right right right
yeah it was thought you know tricky and
hard to see yeah I mean I start do you
look do you trim your pubic hair are you
fully pushed it depends when when when
the time you know
and when it was probably some bush
happening at that's right visibility was
low oh yeah there's a lot of
bushwhacking going on man when and so
this this son of a [ __ ] gave you Lyme
disease yeah I started found really
shitty Oh horrible and now it's like
it's not you know why I'm is a terrible
thing I mean I don't have it as bad as
some people but it's kind of just with
me now like everything wrong well a year
this happen about three years two years
ago maybe and yeah so like once every
you know when's the twice a year now
like I always have like really bad
migraine like body ache it kind of shuts
me down for like a day it's just like
with me even though I went on
antibiotics one nice it's something that
sometimes it gets rid of it completely
sometimes it just lingers with you so
what is the kind of moral of this story
I'm wondering don't hike don't cut don't
go I gotta tell you
well I'm sorry you got Lyme disease
awful but on the plus side I mean the
masturbating probably was was definitely
worked in your favor and this time
really so is that it the longer that
takes in you the worse the Lyme disease
yeah because I had a fight another time
like and I noticed I know for a fact I
noticed it with him like you know an
hour so for the most part people say it
have to be in there for like 24 to 72
hours learn that to be transmitted I'm
very glad you decided to they're very
glad you decided you masturbate that on
that when you did and I thank you for
sharing for sharing that story with me
but I'm also curious what is it you said
what the hell are you doing out in the
forest you're looking for treasure
I guess my call it's called geocaching
so basically what it is is someone like
me or whoever else geocaches hides a
container somewhere out in the woods or
out there's foam in this I mean there
are over three million of these
geocaches around the world basically
people go look for them they use like
GPS coordinates to find where they are
once you're in the location the try to
find a no is it is there something
valuable yeah what do you find what's
going on in this box is other than just
well ticks with Lyme disease do you
still do you still geocache always a
run-through yeah god bless I definitely
have ruined being outdoors I'm Way more
paranoid now whenever I am out in the
woods I used to like do tick tick check
only whenever I got back to the car
after you know I was done now it's like
every 20 to 30 minutes of the trail I'm
like well let me check yeah and well
thank you Kyle for sharing your story I
hope this is a cautionary tale everyone
out there don't go outside I mean that's
the moral that I pulled from this
Yeah right exactly the graphical clean
and covered my dear thank you for
sharing that wonderful story with us and
I wish you all the best and I hope that
Lyme disease you know yeah keep cash in
my dog always always end with the wet
one my dude
thank you well that was an interesting
ride man we've got Travis here who uses
female razors for [ __ ] shaving only
that's not that surprising but favorite
author says he's a sandpaper Ian what
the hell is this he's shaking his head
no I don't know he said he said where's
the box guy that guy still don't know I
just need Travis he's talking about
razors and John Oh bummer well we can't
that was a great one now that's not
happy with Kyle hard to top this story I
mean it didn't it didn't really add to
our knowledge base
was oh great yeah I don't know if we can
join the great minds he's not a great
way elect I mean he's a poor minds
collective he got on a dick but he's a
great guy and he's a funny guy you know
interesting guy can't believe you guys
never did the geocaching thing that was
you know about it yeah I went on a few
of those then we don't it was big like
while ago have you have you have you
done have you ever done this thing
walking outside
forget about geocaching that's way too
high level for us um Wow
Thank You Kyle that was a great story
damn you don't I've got I've had a
ticket before of you sorry you didn't
maybe I have Lyme disease maybe that's
why I'm so lazy when that be great to
have an excuse yeah
now it's dramatic man it's awesome oh
god it's a [ __ ] little creature I
hear that but Lyme disease is more
prevalent on the East Coast oh yes
you're good why did ya anyway Kyle love
you let's move on 87 year old woman
taste take the old [ __ ] out what'd I
say
she had it coming I love these stories
about police no let me let me let me say
this okay I respect police officers I
respect the job I respect what they do
but I have a lot of busts first of all
you signed up for a dangerous job and
you're well compensated you can go work
in a [ __ ] cafe if you don't want to be
in harm's way
okay nobody asked you or forced you to
sign up to be a cop the same goes for
the military and I'm sorry but my
opinions are the right opinions and if
you disagree with me you're just clearly
wrong why do I first of all I respect
well I felt this story so people can
join your 87 year old woman pace while
cutting dandelion
there's no justification so I'm gonna
tell the story though but I'm onna I
wanna I want to okay should be blah
about the rant about the military okay
let me just say that finish this one
point as you know to save me being in
the military doesn't make you a hero by
default but thank you for your thank you
for your service you signed up did it
it's a risky job it's there it's the
first part you go you travel around with
a gun and hostile territory same with a
cop you walk off the gun on your hip for
a reason it's dangerous and you signed
up for it
it doesn't make you automatically a hero
and it doesn't mean that you have the
right to never be in harm's way because
the police training in the United States
is basically if you are an any risk
shoot to kill a deadly force when you're
confronted with the 87 year old woman
with a steak knife in her hand that was
used to cut dandelions which is adorable
as [ __ ] gas to make a salad for a
husband God so she's out there cutting
dandelions and the police first of all
that she wanders across the street she's
probably a little she doesn't speak
English and she was on some guys
property she probably didn't know it was
a it was the YMCA or some [ __ ] or the
Boys and Girls Club okay but they call
she was probably a little dementia core
a little senile right so the guys calls
I have a record him but he says she's
over here with a knife and she seems
lost that's why he called they're like
is she trying to stab people he said no
she's not dangerous she's not trying to
harm anyone she seems lost that's why he
calls so the police show up with arms
their guns drawn screaming you know drop
the door can you imagine that a sweet
old lady with a little like steak knife
cutting dandelions like what's going I'm
at a zoo shredder like you cannot you
have to draw the line somewhere you
signed up for a dangerous job okay you
have to draw the line somewhere if some
87
the choice between tasing an 87 year old
woman and possibly receiving a knife
strike from an 87 year old women you
have to weigh the severity of these two
situations can you imagine this Olli 87
year old to [ __ ] a ah she's all fast
to jet all of a sudden she's like oh I'm
an 87 over she's all strong it fast out
to kill no the training is [ __ ] it's
[ __ ] you are not entitled to a perfect
harmless existence because you're a cop
you signed up for that job and I
appreciate that you're serving the
community and you're doing this
wonderful dangerous job that somebody
has to do but you could have gone you
know you could have could have done
anything I just feel like any normal
person in that situation would like the
thing was that she was walking towards
them when they said drop the knife and
she didn't drop the knife but it's like
if you were in that situation what would
you do you just shoot you'll let her
walk to you and you'll deal with it
don't draw a gun don't say hi can I help
you or you okay it's like an old lady
knife down how about you just go and
grab her hand yeah takes a knife out of
her hand because she's an 87 year old
woman how about you just do this are you
okay drop the [ __ ] gun
take what's affordable will chew you
[ __ ] it's a problem here guys there's a
problem with our police killing people
she didn't die but let's watch the story
boiler alert either you've ruined the
story yeah now two major questions after
an officer in Georgia tased an 87 year
old woman who was cutting the Lions with
a knife Steve osunsami is annotate you
take what's up for debate tase your ass
imagine that imagine that mmm just look
at her that's so sad
mm she probably hit the floor like a bag
of dirt
she probably hit the floor like a bag of
dandelions she probably got injured
alive to fall in this age yeah you don't
heal very fast if you think the price
she's alive I mean frankly speaking I
mean God look at that threat than that
menace to society damn she had it comin
woman is actually facing charges this
morning oh that's the best part I didn't
even tell you the best part
well I'll let them speak for it she's
getting charged it is this is a
misunderstanding
on so many different levels it's not our
tasting charges but she has a court
appearance next month this 87 year old
grandmother who doesn't speak English
and bail man my wife is charged this
morning with criminal trespass and
obstruction of an officer a worker at a
Boys and Girls Club in Chatsworth
Georgia called police Monday after
seeing her walking with a knife in a
field on their property it turns out she
lives across the street and is from
Syria it was a steak knife and she was
basically mad and all this which her
family experience it was a steak knife
like a kitchen knife and she was there
picking dandelions which her family
explains was meant for a salad for her
husband police say she even had a bag
full of cut weeds even the worker who
called not weed the old [ __ ] got weed
take her out sprinkle a little crack on
her she was mysteriously found with
crack on her this 87 year old crack
addict pulled a weapon with a bag of
weed on said she wasn't threatening
police arrived with guns drawn telling
her to put down the knife but say she
wouldn't they say they even threw a
knife to the ground trying to explain
put down the knife
she won't put the knife down
they explained she wouldn't put the
knife down mmm got him being what they
wanted her to do when she kept walking
towards them they shot her with a stun
gun the police chief was there during
the incident to pull the Taser rather
than using deadly force
he says his officer acted appropriately
her family says at her age the shock
could have killed her she's recovering
you know still killing anyone nobody
should be tasered but especially boy
yeah I mean if it's like a 30 year old
man a young 18 year old man woman sure
protect yourself but I love that the
police chief comes out and is like oh
yeah no they they reacted perfectly we
we we endorsed fully tasing Grandma's
children really if you're stepping
towards us we're gonna take or if you're
walking away from us we'll still things
yeah will tase you in the back mm little
sore from what she's gone through facing
charges and there's one thing we should
add about that young man who is speaking
out for the family Robin he is the
nephew of this woman and he's a former
police officer and he says while he
understands why the officers used their
taser he wishes they had used a little
more common sense yeah thanks for
bringing that up Steve very much yes the
nephew said procedurally the officers
did the right thing but it's kind of
like being aware of the surf exactly
that's a problem procedurally it's all
good but it's like it's an 87 year old
woman loved it yes and maybe it was a
little sometimes everything is not
exactly by the book mm-hmm well the best
part she's being she has to appear in
court for like cruising around with a
knife now they're gonna charge her to
make it look all kosher it's like let's
just let's not waste the justice
system's time either she's being charged
with criminal trespassing and
obstruction of an officer you've tasered
her bro
so how was that was that rageful you
could say that polls reveal in the UK
that people want Edra Elba to replace
Daniel Craig as double-oh-seven James
Bond but here's the catch
ela yeah he's black oh he's a black man
apparently that's caused a lot of drama
people say James Swan has to be white
here's my take you want my opinion here
mm-hmm you want to know you guys want to
know how to feel about this I love it
I love I love a dress Elba I mean people
voted for it well what else do you need
that's the best part this was a public
vote in the UK with a list of five names
and people voted for a dress and I love
that now and ones like oh you can't be
born because you're black when I heard
that I was like oh I love that not not
even this is why I love this story so
much it's almost like heartwarming how
much people haven't thought about race
in this because when I heard that I was
like this ed I just loved him as an
actor he's suave he's cool he's a badass
ever since I saw him in the wire I've
been in love with him as an actor I
think he's great and I think he'd be an
awesome dope like double-oh-seven I
thought it was great but apparently a
lot of people are unhappy with the with
the scoop in fact there's a video that
some girl made was it you said Dan about
it about her this is well in general
it's like well here this guy James Bond
let's watch this video first I guess but
that's dude somebody made a really great
point here they're like James Bond
English Americans Scottish Australian
Welsh Irish it's like all of the other
actors that play him yeah it's yeah it's
like
he's an idea he's cool he's suave he's a
spy he's a badass of all the things I
think about when I think of
double-oh-seven white is not like number
one oh he's a white guy double-oh-seven
white cool suave like down at like
number 15 or something I don't it's not
on the list list right
you're like think you can hop if you ask
someone right top ten attributes of
James Bond if you write what you're kind
of weird white wanna make some great
points also I love her intro Dan pointed
out to me the world is in crisis Wow
look at this everything is going to hell
all right the stage is set
Hopkins world is really powerful why is
it okay here we go
thanks bones you will not be why do you
say it like you will not be like is that
a woman how do you know why are you so
sure about that
over my dead body
but so how many tweets you put out
saying I'm Elba dedra's elbow it's not
because you're a gentleman of color it's
because a gentleman of color you don't
like black people do you lady a
gentleman of color James Bond isn't he's
written as an upper-class arrogant white
top born with a silver spoon in his
mouth why can't that person be black do
you hear what you're saying
he's written as an upper-class snobbish
silver spoon in the mouth okay is that
just white people okay should buy eaten
and Sandhurst well-connected by his
Swiss Family fortune and it's not about
Talent Idris many people love I love how
she was like ranting at him it was all
in there I didn't even ask to be
included in this ball and he just made a
tweet joking about it and now all of a
sudden like
he's getting [ __ ] for this poll when
people made a popular vote they they
would like to see him in it almost more
than you do yourself but please can
someone on your team come up with their
own ideas or their own material
must we perpetually crowbar in gender
and color where it doesn't fit our
imagination apparently it wasn't his
idea first of all and second yeah it's
like it's like she's the one crow boring
in yeah race isn't a part of James Bond
he's just a guy he's a spy he's a
cool-ass spy the fact that he's black is
incidental and he's British by the way
he's got a cool slick Ashe British
accent when I think James Bond British
is what I think right not black or white
or whatever he's a British spy he's got
a dope accent that sounds cool he [ __ ]
like crazy he's a badass spy and you
looked down the you know that wise might
be yeah this might be can we stop making
everything about race it's like no one
was sounds good to me man
the way we love these characters matters
as evidenced by the outrage when someone
attempts to mess with the things we love
so you see Idris it's not about your
color or you
it's about bond James Bond how dare she
say that I love how she's directing it
towards him he's like what the [ __ ] did
I do and it was just an actor I had some
other thoughts but it's already been a
long something about it you know I
disagree I didn't he'd be great and I
hope he gets it and I'd like to see what
she's gonna do about it
you will not Yvonne I like to see what
you're gonna do about it lady it's gonna
find the footage right sounds like a
threat does matters I love this I love
the term gentleman of color
why do you why do you have to put it
like that just say black dude it sounds
less weird he's a gentleman of color
have you met my friend Tony he's a
gentleman of color really right that's
weird - don't say that
Oh the black guy excuse me they
preferred gentleman of color no evidence
by the outrage when someone attempts to
mess with the things we love so you see
Idris it's not about please don't
attempt the thing and to mess with the
things I love which is being white okay
how did I do they get through that you
need a rating after every I don't know
why yeah guys listen
that's just my opinion I don't think
James Bond needs to be white
oh she was saying wait where did I saw
this one a video of someone saying that
it was like as if a white person played
a black role what was that I didn't see
that clip what did I see that Dan hmm I
remember that too it cracked me I was
just thinking the last little chunk of
that did you finish out that there was
this great clip that just had me rolling
or she was like what did I miss
she says like that's like having a what
that's like having a white person play
Kunta Kinte from roots right and I was
like that's about race where it's
explicitly about that's about race it's
not the same get dumb-dumb
let me try to find it I don't wanna
watch this video oh we watch this short
one on Twitter yeah alright let's finish
this [ __ ] damn we watch the wrong one
damn how could this happen
why did this happen
the Cold War era and that's the glory of
the thing a throwback I mean watch okay
it's because James Bond isn't he's
written as an upper-class arrogant white
top born with a silver watch again
well-connected to play Winnie Mandela
bender and color where it doesn't fit
and how come it does work the other way
if I was to play Winnie Mandela how
would that go down she's a cat I don't
know why would you even swai would you
want to play mad I don't know what she's
talking about it looks like she's like
what if I played a black slave how would
that go down pretty bad cuz it's about
race James Bond has nothing to do about
race and pot and identity and she's
talking about the wife of Nelson Mandela
so it's like explicitly about apartheid
it's a fictional character that's a real
person that's black about apartheid and
what if I played Hitler and a film I
think I would upset a lot of white
supremacist and that's just not right
frankly Oh
I'm seen as a cow what's the issue watch
her a white shaft [ __ ] shut the [ __ ] up
shaft was a film I don't need a play
with us anymore I think we get it played
the wrong one I would like to see uh
would you watch white shaft dealer I
actually don't know them I don't know if
I've seen shaft what is Jeff sick Grand
Jury Oh God not this one we can skip cuz
there's a lot of stuff grand jury report
no Allah our duty is to report the news
we are here to report Kern events and
news and culture and to tell you guys
how to
can feel grand jury report Catholic
priests ran a child porn ring and six
Pittsburgh basically throughout
Pennsylvania this this is shocking to me
I guess let's start with this video this
this is horrifying
wait is this in here yeah now this is
this is just plain evil I mean I don't
really know what how else to describe
this in Pennsylvania there is an
epidemic an actual pedophile ring okay a
priest 300 priests I don't know how many
priests are in Pennsylvania but I can't
imagine more than like a thousand I mean
I don't know it's the number but what is
that what is that thirty percent that's
a whole state and it just it kind of
pisses me off because you're seeing a
lot of people all these conspiracy
theories about like satanic pedophile
rings like this queue and on and pizza
gate and all the [ __ ] Alex Jones goes
off he says like the world is run by
sick man and pedophiles Roe look at your
own [ __ ] church this is the most evil
[ __ ] I've ever heard in my life yeah how
can you talk about pizza gate when the
Catholic Church is literally a satanic
cult when you have three hundred priests
systematically abusing kids in
Pennsylvania everybody in that
organization knows it's happening
everybody the priests that's part of the
stories that they were covering up but
how are they and I'm am I supposed to
believe that they're not all
participating how can you let that
evilness slide in the church like their
whole thing is community and serving God
and like and so how am I supposed to
believe that over the course of
many decades you can have that many
pedophile priests you're covering up and
you're moving them around and you're not
all in on it not just covering it up
who's only everybody what do you mean
everybody if 30% of the people that work
for you are [ __ ] kids like what what
what reason do you have to keep that
system moving if you find a pedophile
you can't come out and you apologize
when you have 300 and you're covering a
lot you're perpetuating a system that
you probably want to keep going I think
there's a lot more of these guys [ __ ]
kids than just the 300 yeah and it's
just so funny and ironic to me that
people will go slander and and say
dangerous [ __ ] like pizza gate and
basically make up you anon and all the
[ __ ] say Obama's a pet we know when you
have this wrong like and and the [ __ ]
that you're gonna hear is gonna make
your sprinkle I mean this is really evil
stuff so just prepare for this is
shocking do I sound like a conspiracy
theorist like I'm basing it on something
well I'm not sure what are you
everybody's in on the [ __ ] everybody
the whole church not the not the people
not the congregation but like all the
priests the bishops well yeah I don't
know I'm hunger and the Pope I don't
know the Pope people were saying what
was the last Pope that resigned that
never happened people speculate that he
was [ __ ] kids and he didn't want it
to come out
imagine the Pope is raping children and
you're talking about pizza gate what do
you really that it makes me think it do
you really care about kids or is it just
a political attack yeah did this [ __ ] is
so upsetting numbers about child sex
abuse by priests it found credible
allegations exist against more than 300
priests
and that more than 1,000 child victims
were identifiable what is worse because
of lost records or fear of coming
forward it is likely the true number of
victims is deep into the thousand Gingka
Soros has been working this for us in
tens of thousands mostly our massive
investigation and it was with countless
numbers of law enforcement prosecutors
other attorneys within the office of the
Attorney General and of course the grand
jurors officials are saying that this
report is the largest most comprehensive
document into child sexual abuse within
the Catholic Church that has ever been
produced in the United States this
report took two years it was written by
23 Pennsylvania grand jurors who
listened to dozens of witness
testimonies and which is just in the
state's abuse in six diocese which is
about 54 of Pennsylvania 67 counties the
report states that the testimony was
heard from dozens of witnesses and half
a million pages of internal documents
were subpoenaed it also states that
there were credible allegations found
against over 300 priests over 1,000
child victims were identifiable but it's
believed that the true numbers are way
more thousands way more priests
waymarsh's boys but girls were also
victims some routines some were younger
some were manipulated with alcohol or
pornography they were raped in various
forms and fashions and grand jurors
found that church leaders in every part
of the state preferred to protect the
abusers and their institution above
everything else they listened to that
every part of the state every part of
the institution every single time as a
church policy to protect the institution
at the cost of the abusers perpetuating
a system it's basically what exactly
does the Catholic Church do except rape
kids I mean what exactly would you say
you do Catholic Church are you enjoying
that tax exemption
I mean I'm disgusted I'm repulsed like I
think it's time to close it down
I think it's time to walk shop up on
that church imagine any other [ __ ] I
mean I'm really upset imagine
Scientology I mean which I [ __ ] my
eyes imagine any organized religion
being like oh yes sorry we raped all
your kids you need to imagine what
Scientology
yeah I'm but I'm saying imagine this
scope of like all the kids are being
raped in Scientology
yeah watched A&E sorry is that example
no need to imagine yeah okay that
example they're all [ __ ] up but what
exactly do they do there why are we
giving them a tax exemption and this is
evil you guys this is just actual evil
it's like like all the weird
conspiracies you hear about pizza gay
and like weird child sex torture and
basements is happening in the Catholic
Church yeah wait do you hear say because
the cover-up was most important for
these petitioners is Alex Jones ranting
about this I don't know maybe he is I
hope he is I'll be pretty weird if he
wasn't I don't know how you can bring up
pizza gate or queuing on and not this
all day I don't know you can't talk
about this all day if you care about
pedophilia and for a time some of the
diocese sought to prevent the entire
report from ever seeing the light of day
in effect they wanted to cover up the
cover-up they sought to do the same
thing that senior church leaders in the
diocese we investigated who have done
for decades burry the sexual abuse by
priests upon children and cover it up
forever the report states that because
of the cup of it almost all of the be
abused is too old to be prosecutors were
story has issued presentment against two
priests so out of the 300 300 plants
they're only they cover
for so long that these guys have passed
the statute of limitation and can no
longer be charged except for - I mean
that's a criminal law organization that
knows what it's doing folks
right round of applause to these guys
let's give them tax exemption let's make
sure they never have to pay taxes it
gets crazier here I'm gonna read some
facts here I've got about this this is a
quote from one of the victims George
claims that's that the priests began
taking photos of him on a camera all the
priests giggled
so there's many priests involved in this
one location then added photos of him to
a collection of other teen boys
according to the grand jury these men
and another priest were part of a ring
of predatory priests that rape children
shared intelligence of potential victims
and manufactured child pornography in
parishes and rector ease this group of
priests used whips violence and sadism
and raping their victims reads one line
in nearly 900 pages of documents hello
is the whole world talking about this I
mean I know people are talking about it
but Dan just looked he said nothing on
Infowars about it I mean the story's a
couple days old but like hello this is
kind of insane you guys yeah and this
isn't just the United States there's
crazy in Argentina in Ireland this I
mean there was huge stories about child
abuse
mm-hm it's like pedophiles are literally
just joining the organization
we shocked sadism she whips violence and
sadism and raping systematic raping what
I want to religious people after hearing
this would still send their kids do
whatever it is they're sending them to I
don't know it's a good question it's the
Catholic Church I mean it's the Catholic
Church the Pope where does the buck stop
where's the buck stop who's taking
responsibility for this are we as a
society taking responsibility for this
that our kids and our citizens and our
fellow our fellow citizens our children
are being raped and the guys who did it
are being covered up for so long that
they can't even be charged these guys
are chilling dude mm-hmm
they're at our local parks and I'm not
and I'm not I'm being serious
see it wasn't the what was i saying
earlier serious is what as the school
shooting I forgot what it was thank you
this world is so [ __ ] you guys why are
we not pizza gate we have sir if you
imagine being this [ __ ] they're only
there was an email about a pee a
handkerchief with the pizza and upside
down it looks like a pedophile are you
[ __ ] kidding me
let me read this again the group of
priests use whips violence and sadism
and right raping their victims but at
the hankerchief upside down why aren't
you talking about this genius you don't
need any more [ __ ] evidence my skin
is crawling and there's more in and like
the details of what they've done it's
horrible it's even just horrible to read
the report said the mint here this is
this is so [ __ ]
dude if you could top sadism I mean this
is part of the state report said that
the priests gave a specific gift to
children they favored something they
could wear that would mark them as prime
targets for abuse
he said they told me that they the
priests would give their boys their
altar boys were the favorite boys these
crosses he'd George told the grand jury
so he gave me a big gold cross to wear
that marked him so all their other
priests knew he was fair game for abuse
can I get another look at that
handkerchief
there's no need for conspiracies guys
this is as [ __ ] as anything your
imagination can comprehend almost every
instance abuse we found is too old to be
prosecuted mmm here's some more
highlights in green burl a priest
impregnated a 17 year old girl forged a
pastor's signature on a marriage
certificate and divorced the girl months
later another precinct greensboro
groomed middle school students for sex
according to the grand jury by telling
them that Mary had to bite off the cord
and lick Jesus clean after the Nativity
what does Q and onl have to say about
the well never mind this I can't wait to
see why what what what Obama and George
Bush and Bill Clinton and Hillary
Clinton let's hear more about their sex
ring
in Harrisburg a priest abused five
sisters from the same family and
collected samples of the urine pubic
hair and menstrual blood this is like
you've seen that show true detectives
how it's like so sick and twisted beyond
imagination this is real nothing yeah
you know the this the phrase stranger
than fiction can't make this [ __ ] up
yeah
in Harrisburg a priest raped a
seven-year-old girl who was in a
hospital after her tonsils were removed
in Pittsburgh this this is just the
highlights that they got yeah this is
just one state one area in Pittsburgh
Church officials said that a 15 year old
boy pursued and literally seduced a
priest church officials that was their
statement and defense of the priest that
a 15 year old boy pursued and literally
seduced a priest
well I guess that clears that up a
Church report later acknowledged that
the priests had admitted to Sado
masochistic activities with several boys
are you sick yet yes I feel like people
forget about this everyone's just like
oh man there goes the Catholic Church
again I'm ready to lock it up I don't
think these guys their library card is
being revoked what's going on this is
the most evil [ __ ] I've read in
Allentown a priest admitted sexually
molesting a boy and pleaded for help
according to documents but was left in
ministry for several more years priest
rapes a child he begs for help and they
leave him there for several more years
hmm it's just it's so horrible it's like
how do you even what do you even say
what I want to see action because we've
been talking about this [ __ ] for like
decades mm-hmm and it's just getting
worse and worse here this is a wonderful
one Allenstown a priest who had abused
several boys according to the grand jury
was given a recommendation to work at
Disney World by the church they
conveniently left out the part where he
was a convicted child rapist would this
priest be good can we get a reference
for his job at Disneyland he's gonna be
in a Mickey Mouse outfit taking photos
with kids great guy loves kids
really really loves kids great with kids
highly recommend well he wasn't
convicted right none of these guys well
the church knew right no no it's going
to them yeah that's too old right
and Scranton isn't that where the
offices sure is the electric city mm-hmm
I pray my god a priest who was later
served prison time for abusing children
was found to have been HIV positive for
years like he would [ __ ] care
according to CBS the Pennsylvania grand
jury report investigating the matter
States the church officials gave a
former priest a positive reference to
work at Disneyland
even though officials fielded at least
one allegation about a sexual abusing a
boy the report says he worked at the
theme park for 18 years driving the
train to the Magic Kingdom
well isn't that a nice little analogy
pretty creepy all aboard the ride to the
Magic Kingdom his favorite ride Peter
Pan where boys never grow up likes
you know this reminds me when I was a
kid and my neighborhood that was like a
a religious neighbor
I guess they had like a a I don't know
what you call where you go to like
classes when they teach you there they
talk about the Torah and they teach you
mm-hmm so like on Saturdays they would
tell all the kids in the neighborhood to
come and do they give popsicles mhm
so I remember wanting to go and my dad
was like he was up
you're not going to this stuff cuz like
now that I think about it's pretty weird
why you're inviting kids and giving them
popsicles why you want all the kids over
there yeah with like this irresistible
invitation yeah oh yeah it's so easy to
be deviously hide behind religion that
was really slick of your dad by the way
yeah I wonder if people knew or if you
just had the insight or Yeti and that
was always very paranoid about this
stuff and for good reason mmm-hmm I mean
it's it's so ironic
obviously that like under the guise of
God and this whole institution of cracka
is the most evil evil evil [ __ ] we all
agree in this society everybody agrees
like child rapists are like the worst
right look we all agree mm-hm somehow I
mean at this point if you give your
church if you give your kid over to the
church I mean you're pretty much taking
a crapshoot pretty much there's like a
really good chance they're gonna get
molested [ __ ]
that should really I don't know man it
just pisses me off because there's all
these stupid [ __ ] conspiracies that
are ruining with like so little evidence
that it's there's no evidence it's a
total conspiracy that are [ __ ] with
people that have nothing to do with this
[ __ ] and they're ignoring it's making a
joke of this serious actual well they're
just using it as political attack and it
can't be more obvious than this because
they're not talking about the church but
somehow Obama is a pedophile Hillary
Clinton's a pedophile okay
it's shocking man it's so evil
it's so [ __ ] you how can you allow
organization that's covered up that
treachery that evilness for so long
continue to exist they should be ran out
I really wonder like what did the normal
people think like actual religious
people well I would like to know yeah
can we get calls of Catholics like you
gotta assume that your priest is most
likely a pedophile I'm really curious
what people are gonna think I mean
everybody's covering it up okay what's
it what's the number eight eight eight
oh eight Dan hot meme eight oh eight hot
meme which seems if there's any
Catholics listening I'm gonna clear the
call queue if you're on the if you if
you've been holding sorry guys getting
hung up on deal with it if there's a
Catholic listening there's a strong
opinion about this give me a call I'm
interested in people that disagree with
me I want to hear how you think I'm
wrong about the church well they know
well I'm saying like close it down so is
it not as bad as I mean it seems like an
arguably bad buy either way I want to
know what Catholics think about this so
meanwhile as we populate some calls
we've got
the casting thing that I don't really
care about honestly and then we've got
the this I do like Kevin Spacey
billionaire boys club movie came out and
it earned a hundred and twenty six
dollars on opening day it was a limited
release it was on like ten theaters but
no okay but Adele $126 that's like ten
people it's actually less probably
that's just friends and family that's
that's not even friends and family there
was like thousands of people involved in
that movie probably yeah 126 bucks [ __ ]
you could made that work in that damn
it's [ __ ] up that one person can [ __ ]
up a whole project you know for everyone
involved
apparently it was a really awful movie
though mm-hmm I saw in Rotten Tomatoes
they had like 5% or something so I mean
the name billionaire boys club got a
better name that's got to be
embarrassing though you should wish I'm
not gonna say it I was gonna make a joke
it's probably inappropriate as
inappropriate as raping kids as a priest
though no I feel like I should get a
little more leeway on things well I am
he's been a longtime favor of the
podcast not the podcast of the show of
HD reproductions we've
I've enjoyed will.i.am antics because
he's as far as I mean he's musically
talented I guess not my style but he's
very socially challenged and and he
thinks he's very suave enjoying it wants
to be Kanye he thinks he's Kanye I think
you're right
he is Kanye but I'm afraid he might be
Kanye but without the yay he's more of
like a straight-up con I don't know I
don't know I'm not gonna call him a con
but he's definitely a goofball just
kidding so bite my - the joy of this
rabbit hole we're gonna go down right
now is that I saw this video and then I
found out that there's actually a
subreddit dedicated called cringe I am I
was like wow this guy's prolific Cringer
if he's got his own subreddit [ __ ] well
let's start with this video you know
tell me if you think this is interesting
because this is a welcome voice you can
like you just can't decide we don't
figure out how we work together so this
is for the show and what I think will be
great for the finals there's nothing to
do with how I feel about you being an
artist moving forward so they're running
out of time
like really running out of time
[Applause]
[Applause]
no it's tough
[Music]
yeah it's really not cute but we need a
man
that's its I will buy the - it's gonna
be
[Applause]
oh my god get on with that and then when
he says it nobody cares though whatever
kind of a goofy and not that bad but
like it's really more about the fact
that there's a cringe I am subreddit and
so then I might opt on over to there and
I was like wow there is some good stuff
here so kind of want to go down the list
of cringe I am top of all-time and now
this one is really poignant I would say
it's very educational and might inspire
you a little bit as well
startup of the Year guys tip of the week
what makes a great logo hmm first off
your logo has to be just as impactful in
black and white he so much reminds me of
that kid is like you will you what you
got you got my dream is do it you if
your logo is not Pablo right like his
icon then the ways know very very slick
his eyes are you can't make eye contact
and he starts all around or is on drugs
or something collapses when you blow it
up a really really big then there's a
problem if your logo can't transform
itself to other things and you still
know what that logo is and there's a
problem so your lunch should be able to
have all those things what are they
doing in the editor - camera they have a
camera there and he's looking through
that camera and companies he's not
supposed to dart between here and now
they show it when he's not I know but
you're not supposed to dart between the
cameras they just wanted like a nice
profile shot and he's doing this he's
doing like that I mean what'd I tell you
supposed to do with that he's looking
kind of in between them though
company's objective on a symbolic level
right because it you have to think of
what India is going to do to the world
right we know what Silicon Valley did to
the world what we know what China does
for the world we do but what India's
gonna do for the world is they're gonna
create this symbolic language because
India is unique because they speak
English he's talking about that logo
talking about the logo damn he's awesome
he's on he's on to something
I wonder what his I wonder how he wipes
easy a red jamming or what was it green
jamming yeah know what
green green jamming so they I don't want
to pick up a red gentle going to add a
whole new type of visual connecting
language to the planet you know and
symbology and logos are gonna put a big
role on that understanding something
just by looking at a logo or different
symbols a new language a new type of get
this dial up is where you can talk and
talk about doesn't say anything well
it's like it's really that that ultimate
saying all you need in life to be
successful is confidence and ignorance
it's like if you have that unshakable
confidence if you don't even think about
anything you're saying you never
consider what you're saying you're gonna
sound to some people smart anyway do we
have any callers let's see
looks like we got one what's his name
yam what do you think is this a call
he's saying he's got one on deck that he
thinks will be better so maybe hold off
for a second okay guys well we've pretty
much reached the end but I want to take
this call
I'm canceling cable I'm so sick of
[ __ ] cable me neither well you know
what guys
let's get cable we got it for the first
time ever like a few months ago right
and it's so stupid well we said you know
what people like cable let's try it out
it was almost that's it nostalgic for me
because I used I remember like at my
parents house you could just turn on the
TV and something will play right like
you don't have to choose all the time
right what to watch with Netflix and
those kind of services but oh my god
it's just commercial well first of all
it costs like a hundred and twenty
dollars a month okay which is more than
double pretty much what it would cost to
have every streaming app including like
HBO and Showtime mm-hmm so then there
are so many commercials like the other
day I sit down for breakfast and it's at
the tail end of the show and I'm sitting
I'm eating and I'm just watching
commercials and it's like five minutes
long by the time I'm done with my
breakfast the show's back on and then
let's say you don't like the show you
waited five minutes to see what it's
about
yeah then you want to switch a channel
yeah always it turns on on commercials
yeah
then I can notify pretty much if you
just go Channel up through all the main
channels you're gonna hit commercials
about 50% of the time the other 50% of
time you're about to go into a
commercial yeah like I can watch the
same shows on Hulu without commercials
why am i on cable why do I have cable I
don't get it the only thing is that you
can record shows but I mean if they
never invented that dude but like
and then the other day our recording
thing wasn't working and it's not
recording the show as we want there
really is no reason to have this then
the [ __ ] that's on there flip flop flip
and flop you Pawn Stars it's like the
dumbest [ __ ] that you didn't even know
existed
like I'm happier knowing that these
shows don't exist there are so many
house flipping shows do we need more
house flipping shows you've got a gay
couple you've got a black couple you got
a white couple you got one Asian one a
redhead couple you've got a couple
that's divorced they're in Las Vegas
they're in California they're in Houston
they're in Florida with the lottery the
lottery that was one have we talked
about this before and there's we talking
about it I don't believe these shows
that exist there's a show on home on the
so we must have talked about it there's
one called my lottery Dream House where
they get lottery winners and follow them
to build their dream house with the
lottery winnings I'm like how niche do
you get there's so many news 24-hour
news all day every day so many news so
many people with opinions so many
commercials so many commercials what am
I missing
hmm what am I missing why do people like
cable do we have a call yet I'm just
dragging on trying to waste time ok
Gabrielle here here oh this is a good
one right Gabriella that's the one all
right let's bring her in Gabriella
thanks for giving us a ring no problem
so tell me about so ok you you've been
listening to our conversation about the
Catholic Church I have yes so what's
your reaction to to what I've been
saying um a lot of reaction so it's very
interesting I went through 12 years of
Catholic school and I'm still practicing
Catholic my personal reaction is
usually to just disconnect myself a
little bit from kind of what's going on
in the Catholic Church and just I still
go to Mass there kind of work to
disconnect that piece of it
disconnected the priests the people the
institution itself because then it kind
of gets a little bit pulpy and weird but
for me there's since I grew up going to
church there's something calming about
it but you really have to work to remove
yourself and what's going on because I
guess sounds like telling the priest
will tell you how to go and what you
should believe politically and you know
there's a lot of things that I don't
agree with with the Catholic Church for
they still practice and I still believe
in the fundamentals of that so what as
far as all that yeah go ahead
I was just gonna say it was there
anything I said that upset you no I
think that I think that the sex scandals
has been going on since I've been very
young and part of the way that the
Catholic Church works is that there the
priest moves around from congregation to
congregation before the sex scandal
started for me to be because they
started but they move around from
congregation to congregation to kind of
mirror how the Possible's moved around
and preached so a way of covering it up
was this priests is moving to a
different congregation when in reality
I'm originally from Long Island New York
they would use them to upstate New York
so they would all be in one facility and
then that's when the cover-up would
happen so my high school is actually
they just closed it down and one of the
bishops from that whole Pennsylvania
scandal is actually coming to Long
Island that has been in the news quite a
bit for us so it's just I don't even the
cover up on some of this stuff I don't
know if you soak learn to some of those
Netflix series that go into some of the
crimes but there's one called the
keepers about the cover-up of
in Baltimore right where people were
killed
yep and I have friends that went to that
church and knew that priest and it's
their reaction to kind of the whole
thing it's just it's easy because the
whole little cover-up went through
beyond the Catholic Church and into if
you have Catholics in the police force
that it you know it you just gotten
fella
oh so inch but you you sound sympathetic
to what I'm saying you don't seem to
have it much conflict with with my
claims no I
it sounds very clunky though the way
you're describing is like we've got
Catholics in the police force you've got
them all over the place they're all
covering up I mean it sounds very cold
like yeah some of my family that's very
Catholic very by-the-book well what are
your parents think about it because
they're probably more old-school like I
want to know what's the dissenting
opinion yeah cuz I'm sitting here saying
shut down the Catholic Church
I want to hear someone be like yes I
want to hear somebody say that's your
[ __ ] that's [ __ ] up for saying that
yeah I mean I would disagree with that
right like I wouldn't want the Catholic
Church shut down I would want to see
some of the priests that were molesting
children go to jail I think that it
you're not above the law
you know what I mean but don't but if
you talk to like I'm sorry
I mean if you talk to look go ahead I am
my so you talk to like my stepdad he's
very conservative it's kind of like
there's all over now this one happening
anymore it's all over now they're in
denial about it they think it was a past
problem the people are still digging up
dirt yeah yep it's like if you're yeah
I'm assuming you don't have kids right
now right I don't but I have a nephew
this
was just baptized hmm are you worried
about your nephew being around priests
I mean I feel like you have to be
careful with it right like the Catholic
schooling is a lot different now because
there are a lot less nuns and priests
period which means that there's a lot of
lay people that are teaching those
classes
there's not really a heavy you know
presence of priests like yes we go to
school depends when you're in the
service I was like doing the altar
serving and the things like that that it
seems a little bit more intense and
sketchy but I did I did date one person
that any time it was brought up with
like lie off the handle so you know that
something happened and something like
not great so the results like the
long-term results of it you know even if
you in a therapy to deal with it I mean
it's still there it's like any sort of
abuse sure abuses of you that doesn't
matter well you sound it sounds
sympathetic and yeah so well thanks for
sharing your story yeah I mean well the
truth is if you have an instant I I
don't want to get an argument with you
specifically because I mean you didn't
come to argue with me so that's fine but
like if you have an instant you say you
don't shut down the church well first of
all constitutionally I can't shut down
to church anyway but it's like if you
have systematic cover-up I feel like the
institution has proven that it can be
like why does it exist why does it exist
at all anyway we don't have to I'm not
trying to get argument through but thank
you for calling god bless you appreciate
you and we should I got put I'm not
looking for people to agree with me for
Christ's sake why I don't think you know
most rational people would have well I
feel like what I'm saying is [ __ ] up
in a way because everybody outside all
over the world and being like shut down
the Catholic Church so I'm trying to
understand why what I'm saying is [ __ ]
up well I think that the one point she
made that was interesting and it's
probably true for most is that because
you know that this particular story is
about instances that happened in the
past yeah I think a lot of people
probably think oh we we clean this up
it's not like this anymore you know what
I mean which may or may not be true I
don't know but that's probably how they
rationalize it mm-hmm
it's hard to know it's tricky it's
really tricky gotta be careful in there
when do your kids but isn't that [ __ ]
up the first someone who's an active
member of the church be like you got to
be careful
well yeah all right I've said my piece
about it so disturbing story um
shreddies gone nuts starting to shred
cables here so guys thanks for listening
hope you enjoyed this Tuesday episode
this is the let me tell you what to
think and feel episode those are the
Tuesday episodes the right opinion
episodes remember guys there's not much
time left on these represent shirts you
got it in black you got it in tie-dye
you got a hoodie you got the extra thick
hat sewn like four days left or not even
less right then yeah I think it ends
3:00 Friday at noon so yeah about three
days mmm and make sure to go to Teddy
fresh calm slush collection slash sale
that's up figuring out having a 50% off
sale that's insane in it and how'd we do
really some new items finally pretty
soon in about two weeks
oh yeah we're gonna make a video kind of
a preview for Ethan in yellow before
maybe not maybe definitely I'm excited
you don't want to I just say maybe
because we haven't posted in so long I
don't even if it's like a vlog I just
feel like a lot how do we do how was
this episode it was good emotional
rollercoaster like you said you look at
I feel like feel like an [ __ ] like
expressing strong opinions this is this
is the strongest a therapy that's why
you wanna know this show and I will be
spending a lot of time
a better help I need so much time on
better help it was fine it was good you
see how [ __ ] up I am you guys I'm
having a dialogue on on camera we need
to do this off camera I usually shuffle
is that okay you guys was that show okay
I want you guys to see just how insecure
and how neurotic and anxious of a person
I am on camera because that's what this
podcast is about people say you know
look now he's chewing on the car that is
so cute
you're so [ __ ] cute look you can say
I'm an [ __ ] you can say I'm a Jew
when you says an insult that's not okay
that's true you can say whatever you
want about me you know but I feel like
this is as real as it gets this is live
baby there's no take-backs I might sound
like an [ __ ] I might sound like an
idiot I might sound uneducated my tongue
racist but this is as realizing it
there's no take-backs this is live
okay so forgive me if sometimes I sound
stupid or offensive or you think I mean
there's no editing it out mm-hmm it's
all off-the-cuff this is live this is
Who I am
just like Garth Brooks said and that's
just who I am
there's no hiding from me when it's live
me for myself there's no hiding from
there's no be high for myself when it's
live and so I want you guys to see how
neurotic and insecure and anxious I am
because the truth is you guys probably
think I'm a perfect cool ass dude it
just it's confident always all right
just [ __ ] good what is it but the
truth is boy I don't feel like that guy
ever
and think is important for you to know
that right yeah all right
[Applause]
the only soundboard I need is don't get
in my that's shut my ass down alright I
hope you guys enjoyed it please let us
know if you did or didn't you really
want to know if they didn't I mean if
everyone's like I didn't enjoy that that
I should probably listen Dan will filter
comments me that's not insecure and
fragile I am I don't I can't be comments
it I literally can't even see it
that's how fragile I am you guys I want
you to know I'm a fragile
I am petty I am insecure and I'm deeply
unhappy let you know I brought in the
the podcast theme song which is very
upbeat
so doesn't remember that guys I'm not a
I'm [ __ ] probably more than you are
it's not a dick measuring contest I was
gonna say you have a nice weekend but
have a no it's not a weekend yeah that's
what I'm saying
but this Friday we've got Bert Kreischer
which I'm excited about super funny the
super great guy you finally get him in
the podcast he's one of my favorite
comedians I'm hilarious and shirtless
I'm one if he's gonna wear a shirt it's
good question actually I prefer shirt
speaking frankly but I leave the choice
to him and thinking where is the shy
probably a today he sure did so tune in
on Friday at our usual time I hope you
guys enjoyed this and you've been filled
in with the right opinion thanks for
watching
[Music]